bonjour hamel charrier bonjour florent
on l'a dit les pourparlers doivent
reprendre aujourd'hui il faut en
attendre quelque chose tout simplement
oui mon forcément on doit attendre
quelque chose de ces pourparlers parce
qu'à un moment donné il faut arriver à
trouver un cessez le feu et il faudrait
arriver à éviter l'escaladé de la guerre
certainement les deux parties en sont
quand même conscience que ce soit la
russie de poutine n'a pas intérêt à
s'enferrer dans quelque chose qui dure
des années avec l'horreur de la guerre
et puis de l'autre côté les ukrainiens
n'ont pas non plus intérêt à voir une
population où les civils vont payer un
prix considérable qu'est-ce qui peut
aujourd'hui faire qu'ils se retrouvent à
la table s'ils ont un intérêt commun à
trouver une solution qu'est ce qui fait
qu'ils auraient un intérêt commun qui
s'en sortent et l'un et l'autre est en
fait c'est ça qu'on essaie décelé
qu'est-ce que peut conserver vladimir
poutine en se disant par exemple je
garde toutes les positions que j'ai
acquise à l'est et que du coup je garde
tout le territoire autour de la mer mer
noire est-ce que du coup ils sont
contents très en disant du coup je
renonce à voir kiev et à mettre en place
un pouvoir qui lui seraient plutôt
favorables alors qu'il puisse renoncer à
qui est peut-être qui puisse renoncer à
mettre un pouvoir qui lui est favorable
ça à mon avis c'est plus compliqué toute
la question finalement c'est le rapport
de force voilà et de l'autre côté
zelensky il est là aussi donc vous avez
raison c'est le rapport de force il ya
peut-être quelque chose aussi qui est à
souligner c'est que au niveau militaire
à partir du moment donné où vladimir
poutine prend son espace justement du
côté de la mer noire ce qu'on peut voir
forcément c'est qu'il va y avoir des
prisonniers et que là vous avez des
prisonniers qui sont des militaires
ukrainiens si vous avez des prisonniers
ça veut dire aussi qu à un moment donné
on est dans la balance des changes les
ukrainiens ils ont aussi besoin de
récupérer comment est-ce que des
prisonniers donc ça c'est vrai au fur et
à mesure des conquêtes territoriales de
plaies des mires poutine ça va peser
aussi lourd à l'international je les dis
la france va proposer ce jeudi une
résolution au conseil de sécurité des
nations unies pour exister exigé un
cessez le feu le président français
manuel mac on veut être en première
ligne en tout cas
il a en tout cas initié déjà ce rapport
avec vladimir poutine qui s'est soldée
par un échec cuisant on se souvient que
le président de russes ne lui a fait
aucun cadeau quand il a laissé annoncé
qu'on allait s'entendre et puis
finalement il est revenue en arrière et
qu'il a déclenché la la situation que
l'on voit en ukraine et la communication
est maintenue entre les dom et la
coordination annoncé hier emmanuel voilà
aimé emmanuel macron on a parlé hier et
emmanuel macron avait fait un effort
vis-à-vis du président russe en allant
le recevoir on se souvient
somptueusement à versailles en ayant
plus un geste qui était presque plus
fort quand il lui a fait venir dans sa
résidence d'été à fort brégançon parce
que là du coup il y avait quelque chose
d'un peu plus chaleureux j'allais dire
en quelque sorte celle de 2019 2002 puis
en discutant en permanence avec lui donc
dans ce conditions là la france espère
pouvoir jouer un peu son rôle c'est vrai
que rapidement on voit que aujourd'hui
le rapport de force il est entre
américains et russes et que quelque part
ça se passe entre joe biden et vladimir
poutine et que quelque part ils ont
aussi un peu la même génération ils ont
aussi intégré aussi le fait qu'il faille
j'allais dire aller à l'affrontement
mais c'est là où les européens doivent
récupérer une partie de leurs positions
et c'est là où effectivement que ce soit
de la part d'un allemand où que ce soit
de la part d'un français on s'y attend
or emmanuel macron à tisser des liens